i just don't know about q anon
you do know i don't know no i don't know
you know if you go out and you want to
buy groceries you need
a picture on a card you need id
he wants to host next year's g7 summit
at his own doral golf club
take care of the floors you know the
floors of the forest it's very important
frederick douglass is an example of
somebody who's done an amazing job and
is being recognized more and more i
noticed
ivanka trump the president's daughter is
sitting in
for the secretary of state
remember that incredible night with the
maps
and the republicans are red and that map
was so red
from zuchin tendulkar
trump tweeting the new york times they
are a true enemy of the people i think
we have enough of an interview here hope
okay that's enough let's go this russian
bounty story we have multiple sources
saying
that trump knew all along i was there
for a tiny little short period of time
and it was much more for an inspection
there was no problem during the day
and said quote crazy joe biden he
doesn't know me
but he would go down fast and hard
crying
all the way they'll go out and they'll
vote and they're gonna have to go and
check their vote by going to the poll
and voting that way
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once the state department
is emphasizing to world leaders
that they should stay at donald trump's
hotels and they say the noise causes
cancer you tell me that one okay
trump ordered robert mueller the special
prosecutor
be fired the factory policy is wear a
mask at all times
and trump puts all right we're not going
to go through the whole thing today just
because i have so much to talk about so
uh that
we'll have to pick it up where we left
off at some point in the future let's
put it that way
welcome everybody uh so great to see
uh any number of different people here
we have a very packed
schedule today we're going to hopefully
soon hear from joe biden with a very
strong announcement about electric
vehicles i'm excited for it and
it is just such a pleasure to be here
today and
kicking us off david chadman has already
gifted 20 subs via twitch and michael
bach has signed up
and we actually have usually there's
just
no real reason to promote getting to a
hundred
but today we actually have something
special i have already recorded on
spec as we say in the business not one
but
two videos touring my backyard garden
which is
really strong right now and i have them
ready to go
if we get to 100 today i will debut
here to four unseen 2021 garden videos
okay and we have all sorts of different
elements of nightshades and
fruits and vegetables and it's just
crazy what's going on
so those are ready those are ready and
in order to make it even more hype
uh twitch subs count joinpakman.com
uh of course counts but patreon today
will count double every new patreon
pledge
today from the standpoint of getting to
100 counts as
two okay so uh then
zuke's i'm going to be showing people
eggplants if things go right
so um a lot of very exciting things all
right so let's get right into it
um where to even start
uh where do i want to start oh
i guess um oh there's just so much i
don't even know where to start today
oh okay just to get it out of the way
because a lot of people aren't even here
yet hold on let me see if i've got this
17th
oh okay yeah let me i'm just going to
get this out of the way now because for
a lot of people consider this to be
trash
here's a new jimmy from philly voicemail
i'm kind of cleaning out the computer
it's almost like a like a um
disinfection as trump says we're
bleaching the computer just getting
stuff off of it
here's a jimmy from philly thing
oh wait a second where where are we oh
it's muted hold on here we go
david give me some philly so i sent i
just now sent you an email
tucker carlson program titled
um
classic literature sexual propaganda
i just want to see you cover it to the r
so he can cover it i don't understand a
word of it all right so that's deleted
we've cleared that out of the computer
um everybody relax super chats are
working fine there just aren't any super
chats but they will pop up on the screen
okay so that's the jimmy from
philly stuff and we've gotten that out
of the way
i have a new caller oh wait a second
this is yeah
here's another head up your ass type
caller listen to this
hey david the only reason i'm calling is
because your show is in between my two
favorite channels
and while flipping through i saw your
phone number
so while i disagree with almost
everything you say
be vehemently and i think you should
pull your head out of your ass
and go go then go hang yourself because
you're a pile of [ __ ]
oh my god
[ __ ] love this pile of [ __ ] they seem
to have an audio issue at the end there
all right so there's head up your ass
guy
he doesn't like the show i would ban him
except it's a phone call
uh oh we could ban the voi we could ban
the voicemail number yeah that's true
okay and then i'm not gonna do a lot of
this
i have seven voicemails from a guy we're
calling new crazy
and it's just it's just one after the
other take a listen to this hey david
so you sit here and say that you're
going off of
medical advice in science with these
vaccinations
did he say assassinations
the hell maybe you should look into who
authorized
these vaccinations because it was not
medical people who did
or anyone wasn't at the fda any kind of
science
background would you like to know who
authorized
these vaccinations it was the u.s postal
service
the false okay so that's new crazy
and then they left seven voicemails i'll
just dip in and out of it we're not
gonna do all of it it's too much and you
also sit here and say that you go off
science and you go off doctors and this
and that but all the news stations that
you follow
are disinformation they have been proven
to be disinformation by project vertos
with video project verita that's who
that's who's proven it all right
number three you won't speak on antifa
as they burn businesses down destroying
lives every single day
while maxine waters fuels black lives
matter
so that they can it's almost like he's
reading up some kind of strange poem i
don't know
it's almost like maybe this guy's
nickname should have something to do
with the poem uh
instead of um i don't know
we'll think about it and everything that
the democratic party do
go directly against the bible everything
that the democratic party do go against
the bible sex changes
abortions same-sex marriages
all of that all of it goes against the
bible
all right we're just getting this is
good because we're making good progress
getting through these
think about each of these is three
minutes by the way i'm giving you ten
seconds of each
smart guy with all the people that have
burnt businesses down
sound they all have destroyed more lives
than they helped
they have done nothing but destroyed
lives
because when you burn a business is down
now
now taking away jobs from thousands of
people
okay uh we're almost at the end here's
number six
and have you noticed a prisoner of war
flag that flies above the white house
would you like to know what that is
therefore that is for all the children
that were found in the tunnels
under the white house where they decided
that they were going to worship bail
sounds like a hell of a movie that's for
sure and here's the last one
go ahead david go on your show and
defame
project vertos vertos will be
disposed i bet you won't do it and i
dare you to do it
please do it all right so there's that's
the new poet
uh crazy poet all right very good
thanks to pikens h macy
for the twitch sub number 22 today
also big thank you to ryan nowicki
and demandi lynn who have pledged via
patreon
that's too but patreon counts double
today two times two is four
four plus twenty two two plus four six
carry the zero to twenty six
um and as i mentioned earlier i have
full exclusive video of the backyard
garden
and it will be released into the world
when we get to 100 today so something
really really special
um i have one unban request oh before i
do that let me get to our two super
chats
brian santango huevo
martinez alexander jr says i need to
bleach my eardrums david
fair kevin says hey david in your
opinion will matt gates be indicted even
though he wasn't named in the plea
bargain several co-conspirators were
implicated
i don't know but i if you gave me an
even odds bet
i say he does get indicted that's where
i am right now
a ferret queen says menstruating women
in public is against the bible
true yeah okay jeremy says this is a
comment it is only a comment i am saying
nothing
because doing so is incredibly more
useful to discourse than that crazy
caller
well said jeremy very well said okay
when you get banned on twitch you have
the ability if you want
to request an unban
um one such user has done it and i will
now be adjudicating
that request this is a user who showed
up to a recent live stream
uh oh oh boy i'm not even going to say
their username this person clearly wants
attention
um this user said it's amazing that
anybody gives money to this rich
jew you're donating to a jew
don't you think this and then they use a
a k
word for jew has enough money
then they repeated that and then they
said i am unbannable
you jew rats they were then
banned and their unbanned request
is jew rat so that is a deny
and confirm they have uh
that is a permanent that's going to be a
no for me dog exactly
well said well said so that is someone
uh
relegated to the toilets of the internet
i want to say thank you to turkey burger
for the patreon pledge
it does count as two so even though it's
one pledge it actually gets us to 28.
and um i also want to say thank you to
david
chadman dropping another 20
twitch subs um over on twitch so a lot
of really strong stuff going on
a few other super chats nina says usps
makes me sign for my package but not my
vaccine
also he reminded me of the bring out
your dead guy from the stand
albex ruroni says everything democrats
do is against the bible
i love how supposed patriots don't know
the separation of church and state is in
the bill of rights oh yeah
the most so-called patriotic people
often are really the most anti-american
it's it's something else jody says nice
lid today and by
lid jody means hair yeah it's not bad
today
it's it's uh yeah it's not oh
this back here is a little weird but
what can you do
oh um i got so many reactions
to my post yesterday uh to my video
yesterday
about the israeli-palestinian conflict
i'm going to give you guys this is a
very special um
uh little insight um i'm
we didn't get that many emails because i
just tend not to
about foreign policy stuff but i'm gonna
give you
a sense of the range of messages okay
here's on the one hand this is from eric
eric says hey david
as a jewish american struggling to
articulate my thoughts on the current
flare-up
your thoughts were welcome for their
insight clarity and specificity you are
to date one of the few individuals i've
seen criticizing netanyahu the likud
and rightfully pointing out the problems
with hamas and the issues with
leadership in the west bank and gaza
our views largely align although i've
been doing additional research because
my knowledge is
mostly surface level and blah blah blah
i've not felt comfortable speaking my
thoughts because i don't have the
emotional energy to deal with what would
be
an onslaught even from good friends and
colleagues even though i'm not strongly
affiliated with my heritage i'm highly
sensitized to anti-semitism across the
political spectrum and what i'm seeing
now is not entirely anti-semitic
but so much of it is and it's terrifying
i would have left this as a comment on
the show but this is a topic i have no
interest in litigating with strangers on
the web but i want to thank you
regardless
nice message right here's the other end
of the spectrum
[ __ ] israel from ron
okay so one two
one two one
one two
two one two so i think you get it
um quite a range of reactions
quite a range of reactions all right um
all right thanks to donnell allen who
just pledged
at patreon.com david pakman show and
today only patreon pledges count
double patreon keeps more money
than when you sign up on my website but
they do count double okay
also thanks to hauler back a as well as
cosmos and zac prakowski
hold on here also joey orozco
uh putting us at 54. listen the twitch
thing
um if you should if you know what's
going on with jeff bezos you understand
the importance of using that twitch
prime sub okay
you don't have to use it on my channel
but at this point
it's just are you giving the money to
bezos or are you giving it to a producer
that you follow and what i mean is every
anybody who's an amazon prime subscriber
you get one free twitch prime sub a
month you have to connect amazon and
twitch
you make sure you're using it because if
you don't use it amazon just keeps the
money
you can give it to me or someone else i
mean listen i'll take it i'll take
obviously i'll take it but
make sure you're using the twitch prime
sub it does not renew automatically
you actually have to renew it each month
so a very very important thing
okay let's now get to
oh hold on just one can you react to
stephen
mikhail davis i have no idea who that is
steven mchale davis
i don't know what that is i don't even
know what i would be reacting to
um sorry yeah i don't know
okay um
[Music]
let's see now i had a few other things
we okay we did the israel reactions
we did some of those early things
um oh oh oh oh okay hold on
let me pull this up here three one okay
now i just have to find it
fine i have copious notes here
oh okay yeah so here is another new
caller
this is a new caller that we're
introducing they left me
one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten voicemails on sunday
um let's just listen a little bit okay
new caller new caller let me know if
this is someone you want
featured prominently in the future
hey mr president uh you know i watch the
show all the time
so i'm pretty up to date you know
but here's another off the record you
know
i'm in chicago and a lot of chicago
people are still wearing the mask and
that's fine
because outside you know that's
because chicago and new york they're
kind of
like they don't go with cdc guidelines
they kind of say we're gonna wait and
see our no
watch our numbers you know all right
so that went the full three minutes then
called right back what's that music by
the way
i just seen you [ __ ] rid of a drink
but
then i did i just tried this new bar
right around
and in chicago yeah everybody like is
this interesting or is it sad we'll keep
going a little bit
yes unfortunately today i have to watch
cnn
msnbc in facts just the
[ __ ] and
whatever else but my point is
as i do you do um
what's going on why didn't you cry this
ukrainian guy say
that they're not happy with america
right now
yeah all right then he got i guess into
the
where he loved me part of the night
here we go it's actually just a bunch of
this was at 3 43 a.m love you david
i'll be david pakman what
what the [ __ ] dude what's going on with
this
ukrainian [ __ ] because i'm very careful
about what i watch now
because now we see the different side
yeah um this is 3 47 a.m
long side they might have a drinking
problem okay
at least it's not a drug problem anymore
okay
that explains a lot of what's going on
okay yeah
you i love you david i love you david
but
yeah you gotta like be more honest now
what's going on with your crane i just
went to a
yeah i just don't okay so that's that um
anyway i don't know if that's someone we
want featured prominently on the show or
not
uh but you guys you guys can tell me uh
okay other super chats um
wow david very powerful f word with
elements of toughness impressive
do you think there's any realistic
penalty republicans can put in place to
rein in mgt i think you mean
mtg from more and more escalating and
absurd behavior
um i don't know that they want to i
think they like her crazy behavior
ryan's is given the election law change
is happening in many states do you think
biden will make a good faith attempt
to combat this or push ineffectual
change i think he will make a good faith
attempt but it will not be determined
by biden whether it succeeds
hi from france we now have our own
french fox news called cnews that's all
in for the national front
what do you think we should pay
attention to when it comes to this tv
channel
salute i don't know enough about it to
say jf
but that is interesting can you do a
shout out to vasha's charity stream and
twitch raid he's raised money for
palestine children's relief fund
uh hold on a second
that rings a bell to me
let me look that up
yeah palestine children's relief fund
has been criticized due to its financial
affiliation with the holy land
foundation which was shut down
for suspected funneling of donations to
terrorist organizations
so no i would that's not something i'm
gonna get involved in um
that's not a good that's not a good
connection
daniel johnson says david have you
gotten any shiba inu tokens the next
dogecoin by shiba inu everyone
i've had dogecoin for months don't know
anything about shiba inu
dominic says i did indeed
i did indeed what how should the u.s
intervene in the palestine israeli
conflict
if at all i think uh no i think that
that the u.s should not i mean
i i don't i don't know why uh i i
wouldn't frame it that way
i want to say thanks to mitchell
slagowski mitchell slagowski
just signed up at joinedpakman.com and
his new member number
55 5555. i also want to say thank you
on twitch to uh ben lewitt
them eleven christopher little
seth suspect aura r shaked
the ford t-dog hauler back a
cosmos oh wait no who are those people i
already think so that's
seven putting us at 62
and as i mentioned i have extensive
videos of the backyard garden
and if we get to 100
i will debut those videos three ways
okay twitch sub counts as one
website membership counts as one patreon
pledge counts as two today only
that will count as two really really
exciting
um i see the coverage israel v palestine
but where was the coverage of the
saudi-led u.s backed coalition versus
yemen at least in mainstream media
don't know about mainstream media i
covered that during the trump
administration
um vash had an interview with someone
who was studied on the palestine israel
conflict and inner workings of politics
recommended
okay yeah i'm so busy reading and
producing my show
i just don't have time to watch anything
i wish i did
um okay and then i had one other note
let me find this 865
one other series of voicemails i wanted
to play
oh oh oh this is completely unhinged
here take a listen to this this is
another new caller and you guys let me
know if this is someone you want
involved in the show okay so this
message is for the
racist lying david pakman
do you have show after show where you
going about please we know throughout
the black community we going about white
supremacy being the biggest threat to
community
if you ended all murders committed
against black people
by white supremacists the murder rate
for black people would drop less than
one percent
young black men oh okay so he's doing
i think this is a race realist here's
another one
hey david uh first of all i want you to
know i'm a
bit of a fan i watch show regularly but
what i wanted to say was uh
i believe you to be an incredibly racist
man who is doing nothing to help the
black community
okay um here's another one
hey david i know you're a coward and
you'll never play this on your show
but the fact is you talk about white
supremacy and all this stuff being the
biggest threat to black people
black men okay and then he goes into the
raid i try to keep the race realism
off because it um
it does get demonetized often he just
kept calling back again and again
let's see
hey david i can find about 20 at least
videos on the internet of you claiming
that the biggest threat to black people
is white supremacists
still on that topic here's another one
hey david i really uh would like to know
um
why you never addressed uh the real
threat to black lives
and it pretty it seems pretty standard
racist stuff
i'll i'll do just one more i don't think
we need this guy on the show regularly
yeah
so i said the last time would do but
so i felt so dumb looking all these
messages
listen i think all white supremacists
are complete morons i think anybody that
supported donald trump
is to complete more huh okay but
when i see video after video online
talking about how white supremacists
are this huge all right we're done
that's his topic and it's like
all right that's that's not a super
exciting caller probably will not be a
big player on the show
i want to say thank you to andrew
cravello andrew just made a pledge to
the david pakman show patreon and today
only in the interest of trying to get us
to 100 patreon pledges count double
putting us at 64. i also want to say
thanks to
m northrup grim jaws
run from the sun for the twitch
subscriptions putting us at 67. the goal
today and i'll even
just to prove to you guys that i have it
okay
here is uh wait a second where is the
garden video
i'm gonna just show you because i
wouldn't want you to think that i'm
lying
whoa hold on a second i'm just going to
show you
one image from my garden video which we
will debut if we do get to 100 today
check that out look at that swiss chard
look at this can you imagine
okay this leaf maybe this or some of
these leaves aren't perfect but
this is just a little bit of a preview
okay if we do get to the hundred the
full garden i exp i'm gonna be exposing
my
cukes and zooks figuratively
figuratively of course
okay a few other super chats thanks to
zach green who says keep up the good
work
jf says let me rephrase knowing what you
know about fox news any suggestion to
expose
c news's propaganda it's new here in
france and gaining momentum
all the standard media literacy stuff
look at their guest composition look at
how they frame news stories do they
deliberately skew
and blur news versus opinion
um a lot of pretty standard stuff that
can be done
to call out biased media jc
bing says it is my birthday today would
love it if you would wish me happy
birthday on stream love your content yes
happy birthday jc bing people in the
chat please wish jc bing
a very very happy birthday um
an incredible day an incredible day john
says have you seen vasha's 24-hour
stream for the palestine children's
relief fund no i haven't seen anything
and as i mentioned just just uh
moments ago um that
name rang a bell for me and i just
double checked
and the palestine children's relief fund
has been criticized because of a
financial affiliation with the holy land
foundation which was shut down
for funneling donations to terrorist
organizations
um so i'm not getting involved in any of
that i don't know anything about it
that's what i'm aware of with the pcrf
everybody do their due diligence but i'm
not
telling anyone to donate to anything
that i am not 110
familiar with does adult only laser tag
and airsoft sound like a good bachelor
or bachelorette for you
uh yes that sounds good have i ever been
to beavertail rhode island
i have never been there i know nothing
about beaverdale
what are your thoughts on kirsten cinema
from tucson arizona um
i i don't have a particularly high
opinion of her
great show keep up the good day work
david executive chair
bill ford all right so we're standing by
for joe biden standing by for joe biden
thanks to
bad frog lagubrius as well
for the twitch subs putting us at 69
we will debut the full gardening video
at 100 new members the most
direct way remember to support is always
to go to joinpakman.com that is
absolutely the best way
as we stand by for a big announcement
from joe biden
zachary green says can democrats hold
the house in 2022
they can will they is a different
question
jeremy says boxers are briefs this has
been widely answered
check out my youtube video on boxers or
briefs
i won't even answer it here because it's
been discussed
ad nauseam also thank you to spacex nasa
for the twitch sub
people asking if david chadman on the
heels of 40 subs donated today is now
the top donor on twitch
no inconsolable is still the top twitch
donor with 550 subs donated but david
chadman is now within striking distance
at 363
that that delta is now under 200 so that
is getting very very close
it's much it's arguably closer than it
has ever been
liam says have you ever heard of a band
called guided by voices no i have not
how do i feel about hassan [ __ ] friend
of mine would i ever do an interview
sure if he wants to interview me jody
says grow taters and
onions just do it i've never grown
potatoes or any kind of onion
i would love to grow uh like a green
onion i love i use it frequently
and i would um i'd be very into that
that seems like a great idea
um rolling stones or beetles i'm more of
a beatles guy than a stones guy myself
that's a question from jeremy landry
totally legitimate fair question in
every sense of the word
but uh i am definitely more of a more of
a beatles guy
big thanks to bethany who just made a
pledge on patreon even though it's only
one
pledge today patreon pledges count
twice so that's number 71
and 72. we're doing a little bit of a
double up there
also thank you to rengar 1tp
for the twitch sub i'm actually excited
this garden video has been very much
forthcoming
and i think people are going to be
interested we're going to do a virtual
garden tour
if we get to 100 and we're getting very
close
i think we're definitely going to uh
going to get there
am i growing any types of cheese no
that's not my understanding of how
cheese works
but if i'm not understanding the
question
then let me know but i didn't know you
could grow
cheese donald says at what point will
israel pull out the jewish space laser
that marjorie taylor green mentioned
yeah that's it's bound to come out soon
um i can't imagine it would be too much
longer
um if there's ever been a time to use
the jewish space laser you would think
it would be very soon
extremely soon in fact i would say um
we are this is bill ford we're not
listening to bill ford
but there is a lot of competition
growing in the electric
vehicle space um i have been
uh i'm a convert to electric vehicles
i've had one now for a period of time
and there are so many interesting uh
electric vehicle models coming forward
i got an email from a viewer the other
day saying david i know you've owned
tesla stock for a while
but the ford mock e is great
you'd better sell that stock i say let's
make the pie
bigger make the pie bigger and bigger
and bigger i think that that's a really
great thing
um thoughts on massachusetts lifting
coveted restrictions may 29th
lots of states are doing it um i think
my prediction was that by memorial day
we would see
more than half of states lift
essentially all restrictions
so i'm not surprised you know whether
it's right or wrong that's for the
public health officials to determine
it's exactly what i predicted that's a
pat on the
hold on that's a mallet on the back and
um you know uh i don't know
we'll see how it goes jeremy says
stephen king or dean coons
i've never read anything by dean coons
so i guess i have to say stephen king
and i've only read one thing by stephen
king
i want to say thanks to raunchy rick as
well as rengar
for gifting five subs also amusement
labs has signed up that's
seven putting us at 80. i think we might
debut this video
i think we might because we're getting
close
and nothing's happening over on the
website side though
we should really supplement with a
little on the website i think
by stephen king i read the it's a
relatively new one hold on
stephen king books new
um
which one did i read by stephen king
it's not the imposter hold on
harper's the outsider the outsider is
the only thing i've ever read by stephen
king
yeah i i enjoyed it it's a little too
i don't know i enjoyed it it didn't make
me say i've got to read way more stephen
king
um thoughts on the spanish catalan
conflict i don't know enough
i'm not the person to comment on that i
don't know enough about it david your
garden pictures always brighten up the
streams cannot wait for the full video
any ideas what the announcement might be
thoughts on motorsports i don't know i'm
hoping it's something related to car
chargers and i don't know anything about
motorsports
might even say the laser will come out
sooner than anyone has ever seen
yeah absolutely check out guided by
voices by voices great band
plant the rooted stems of green onions
from the store they grow fast and you
can harvest them several times you can
do the same with sprouted garlic
i am aware of that will the usa ever get
out of the two-party system
and calling everything that is good for
the public communism
maybe as i've said to get out of the
two-party system you've got to do
campaign finance reform because the way
politics is financed in the u.s
just reinforces the two-party system and
i have a number of videos about that
i want to say thanks to firewall cmd
who is new member number 81 today
nanny of many says thanks for explaining
things so well i appreciate that
danny says david is a trained chef who
is morally opposed to factory farming i
appreciate it when people grow their own
food
absolutely this is why i am excited
about debuting i'll give you another
screenshot here's another still those
are my
cukes recently planted okay the trellis
is there
this is another moment from this video
that i will release
today if we get to 100 members those are
my
cukes and then let's just skip to one
other spot
that is my perennial time it is a bush
it came back on its own because it's
perennial
really exciting stuff all right so we're
going to look at that video
in a lot of detail potentially today
uh jessica sends a super super chat any
updates on filling the david pakman show
job
opening yes in the next 10 days
we will have uh our new person starting
and very very excited about it
ian says hey david love the show
question have you heard of right wing
pundits like leo tyrell
gaining traction on fox i'm under the
impression he's an example of someone
taking a
fat media deal from conservative media
i'm not particularly familiar with
him ian fraser with a hundred new
zealand dollar super chat
really powerful david would you please
use this for subs for those who have
needed to
cancel due to covet hardship please
great perspicacity and
insight yeah that's a great idea i don't
know exactly how to do it
we have had i'm not exaggerating here
hundreds of people cancel in the last
month due to financial hardship
i know that you know i'm always supposed
to pretend everything's great
and that memberships are dumping it out
of nowhere
they're really not the last month we've
taken hundreds of cancellations
so i would love it if you helped us
make up for that at joinpackman.com and
everybody gets a thank you
cynin bend has just pledged via patreon
patreon counts twice today
putting us at 83. also thanks to sanc
dem and dans news
as well as lincoln lena
putting us at 86 today big daddy swaps
is number 87. i believe we are going to
hear from joe biden momentarily
a lot is happening at this ford vehicle
center
getting very exciting there
yeah i know some people are furious that
patreon counts twice
it counts twice today my friends i'm
curious if biden will mention tesla's
massive new ev and battery factory going
up in austin
yeah i don't know if that's uh
considered a faux pas to do it
at an event at ford we'll see
momentarily
are you waiting on the schengen to
officially open before booking spain are
you leading to august
ask gabrielle just before going live
i have now held tickets to spain for
august
i'm holding them right now i have a
travel credit from a canceled covetera
flight
that i want to apply to the ticket for
some reason the website's not taking it
so what i've done is i've held
i've held the reservation i've not yet
made the reservation
and i hope to be able to do that later
today
i actually have a wedding to go to in
italy and i'm trying to combine it
with visiting spain barbara fusco
has just signed up at joinpackman.com
barbara you are a hero
a true hero barbara really appreciate it
any thoughts on kids getting killed in
palestine or it's always hamas's fault
right as you say
i have a 20 minute video about that
yesterday okay there's no way to do
justice to that
in a minute i have a 20 minute video
about that yesterday
um thank you also to
kiteable two starks and jazlyn knights
new members 89 90 and 91 today
we are getting dangerously close to
releasing this hell of a video
the garden video and i even have a bonus
second video from the garden
that i may show you later today
um if you're just tuning in you have not
yet missed joe biden we're standing by
for joe biden
at the ford rouge electric vehicle
center
in uh where is this this is in is this
in michigan
do we know i believe it is
yeah nobody knows okay that's okay
um the speech is about electric vehicles
my hope is it will be a blockbuster
announcement
about new electric vehicle chargers
including hopefully some ultra high
speed ones that's my hope
we will see what the announcement is
my conservative parents blame the
colonial gas shutdown on biden lol
yeah that's i don't i mean i don't want
to say your parents are stupid
but that's a it's a really ignorant
thing to say there's no evidence of that
at all because it's just not true
all right here is uh president joseph r
biden jr
maskless in accordance with cdc
guidelines look at that jog
have you ever seen trump move like that
wow stevie wonder
what a day i've never seen trump move
that way
that is something else i love it
my name is joe biden and i'm a car guy
here we go please sit down please
i got through high school and college
and law school
because my dad ran an agency
and uh i'm delighted to be here
i want to say something else up front
i'm standing here because about 180
years ago when i first got elected to
the senate
gov
the uaw elected me
right
we used to have the highest percentage
of auto workers of any state in the
nation because we had a small workforce
and two giant plans plus mopar and a few
other things going on
so i want to thank you look uh and i
want to thank
a good friend of mine michigan governor
gretchen whitmer as my mother would say
gretchen
god love you dear you've got a backbone
like a ramrod
you got a brain as big as anybody in the
business and you are so
honorable i'm so delight to know you and
anything i can do
as i said to you before i'll come
campaign for you against you whichever
will help the most
right that's pretty clever actually i
want to thank angela we were talking
it'll be useful i'll campaign against
you
yeah on the other side of the truck and
uh
i want to thank her very much for being
so gracious
and rory i know you're new to the labor
movement but you're doing a pretty good
job
where is rory rory thank you pal thank
you thank you thank you
and uh and everyone at the uaw for being
the best auto workers in the world
you know uh and i want to thank uh bill
ford and jim farley for hosting us and
investing in our workers and in our
country we're at a great inflection
point in american history
how we handle the next four to ten years
is going to determine where we're going
to be 30 40 50 years from now it's one
of those moments in american history
this is an incredible facility
representative debbie dingle another
dear friend
i know john's looking down and he's
saying we're finally getting it done huh
you're getting it done debbie you're uh
and representative dan kildee is a good
friend
representative brenda lawrence uh and by
the way be careful what you say to
uh representative slotkin she knows more
than you they may be watching you
um i tease her all the time
she's a great great great addition to
the congress
and rasheed talib where's rasheed
i tell you what rasheed i want to say to
you that
i admire your intellect i admire your
passion
and i admire your concern for so many
other people
and it's my from my heart i pray that
your grandmom and family
are well i promise you i can do
everything you see that they are
on the west bank you're a fighter and
god thank you for being a fighter
and andy levin know a lot of levins
and uh hailey stevens i thank you all as
well
and also want to thank mayor jim
o'reilly of dearborn for the passport
into the city thank you mr mayor
and my buddy mike duggan he is my mayor
i got i was sitting one day in the oval
with with barack obama when
president obama when i was vice
president and he looked at me like it
was just something off the
he said by the way i want you to go fix
detroit
i said say that again what am i going to
do
he said you can get anybody in the
government to go with you you
you just do it first call i made was
this guy
you brought it off his knees you brought
it back you're a great mayor and you're
a great friend you got a lot of courage
thank you
[Applause]
and two great friends debbie stabenow
and gary peters who couldn't be here
today because they're back
fighting like hell fighting for this
industry and the people of the state and
for labor
labor industry federal state local
leaders all together
that's america it's best and that's what
i so admire about what bill ford's doing
here
and i you know i wanna so everything
that
these workers this historic complex in
the state represent
uh is something i hope gets modeled
around the country
it's about respect it's about dignity
the dignity of work
my dad used to say joey and i swear to
god when he left scranton when cole died
my dad was not a
was he was a salesperson he wasn't a i
love these stories
great grandpa was so quaint he uh he
said uh
he used to say when he moved to delaware
he got a lead because there were no jobs
and left us with our grandpa
for a little over a year and he commuted
back and forth from wilmington delaware
to scranton
on the weekends and we got back down to
wilmington used to say to all of us and
i was i guess
then about i was going to third grade
and he'd say joe remember i mean this
sincerely
a job is about a lot more than a
paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect
it's about your place in the community i
really mean this about being able to
look at your kid in the eye and say
honey it's going to be okay
it's going to be okay
it's not labor it's union because what
you allow people to do is hold their
heads up
make a decent living and have pride in
what they do
pride in what you build pride in what
you give this nation
and i wanted to be here today the day
before you unveil the next generation of
america's best-selling vehicle
to the entire world to thank you
thank you for showing how we win the
competition of the 21st century
you know how the future is going to be
made but it's going to be made here in
america
made in america
[Applause]
i have to say this brings me home
for more than 30 years my dad when moved
to delaware managed
automobile dealerships in delaware
including the ford dealership
and man that i like that 57 ford
fairlane
oh boy ain't got nothing i think my
grandfather had a 57 fair lane at one
point
all kidding aside that's what got me
through school
and you know i doubt i'd be uh i i
i doubted that it would ever contribute
50 billion dollars 50 billion dollars or
support about 500 000 american jobs at
150.
half the 1 million american jobs 4
supports overall
like the 150 series you know i just got
a tour of the
groundbreaking electric vehicle center
here along with
uaw workers and they showed me the
technology they're using to build this
first ever fully electric f-150
i was able to sit in it quite frankly
i let me see it so i apologize to you
and i won't see it till tomorrow
but you're gonna like it and uh
and i'd sure like to drive it um all
right
i wonder whether or not i can lose the
secret service and go out to the track
oh boy i'm kidding don't you i'm not
look the future of the auto industry
is electric there's no turning back
and as rory says the american auto
industry is at a crossroads
the real question is whether we'll lead
or will fall behind in the race the
future
right whether we'll build these vehicles
and the batteries that go in them
here in the united states rely on other
countries
whether the jobs to build these vehicles
and batteries are good-paying union jobs
with benefits jobs that will sustain and
grow the middle class
someone's going to build right now china
is leading in this race
make no bones about it it's a fact you
know we used to invest
more in research and develop than any
country in the world
and china was number eight
i was extremely number nine oh we now
are number eight and china's number one
can't let that be sustained the future
is going to be determined by the best
minds
in the world by those who break through
new barriers
you know it has china
the largest fastest growing electrical
vehicle market
in the world a key part of an electric
vehicle is the battery right now
80 of the manufacturing capacity of
those batteries
is done in china right
so not the battery for the 150 f-150
we went down to georgia and took care of
that
it allows them to corner the market on
the supplies of raw materials for those
batteries
important almost importing almost all
the
lithium 90 that comes from countries
from like
australia which lead the world in
minding these kinds of critical
materials
and here's the deal it's not that
china's battery technology is that much
more innovative than anyone else's
remember our national labs in the united
states our universities our automakers
led in the development of this
technology but today china has a bigger
manufacturing scale than all other
countries
and they're using that scale to make
these batteries not just in china but
they're making them in germany
and in mexico and now exporting those
electric vehicles around the world
with sights on the american market
and they think they're going to win but
i got news for them
they will not win this race
we can't let them we have to move
fast and that's what you're doing here
[Applause]
[Music]
when president obama and i when barack
and i were in office
that was what we're going to do remember
in 2009
the auto industry was flat on us back
and remember i got criticized by the
president because i was the auto guy
pushing
well guess what we were told
that we'd never be able to sell
american-made cars at the same rate as
before
but we didn't listen we bet on you
the american auto worker we extended a
lifeline and we stepped up
saved more than a million jobs working
the auto industry we set fuel efficiency
standards
provided incentives for folks to buy
fuel-efficient vehicles
and through the recovery act we made the
largest investment in clean energy and
battery technology ever
and the big three emerged from the
crisis in a position
to sell millions of vehicles shot out of
a cannon right here in the usa
but then the previous administration
came into office
they roll back the standards we said
rollbacks that the ford motor company
opposed
despite bipartisan support for consumer
incentives
they let the federal tax credit expire
penalizing
auto workers who are selling the most
electric vehicles at the time
they announced infrastructure week and
they announced it and announced it and
announced it and announced it
every week for four years and then do a
damn thing
didn't get the job done folks
the rest of the world is moving fast
they're moving ahead
they're not waiting for the united
states of america
government labor industry working
together have to step
up and we have a playbook
that'll work we're going to set a new
pace
in the previous administration's
short-sighted rollback
of vehicle emissions and efficiency
standards
setting strong clear targets where we
need to go
it means passing the american jobs plan
to do three things
one transform our infrastructure
our infrastructure is ranked like 38 in
the world
just the united states of america for
god's sake
we're going to put americans to work
modernizing our roads our highways our
ports our airports
rails and transit systems that includes
putting ibew members and the union
workers
to work installing 50 000
charging stations along our roads and
highways nice
our homes and our apartments that's what
we want ibew is ready to do it and they
can
two we're going to boost our
manufacturing capacity
that's why the american jobs plan
invests in new
and retooled union facilities
grants to kickstart new battery and
parts production
loans and tax credits to boost
manufacturing
of these clean vehicles it also makes
the largest investment in research and
development
in generations that's going to help
innovate
manufacture and build supply chains for
batteries and semiconductors
and small computer chips that make
electric trucks and cars
go to be even more reliant than they are
now
it matters the little things matter
we saw last night the united states
senate voted overwhelmingly
to begin work on part of the bill that
i've been pushing
to strengthen our innovation and
infrastructure by investing in research
and development manufacturing that's
pretty underwhelming they voted
to begin work on part of what i'm
proposed like i know
we get this is the process but it's
underwhelming i get it
and you're members of congress here in
michigan they know the value of
manufacturing as well as anyone
and are vital in pushing forward that
bill and others
never again should we be in a situation
we face today with semiconductor
shortages
the united states can't manufacture
semiconductors
maybe the beginning
you know
i think some people think i'm too uh
too proud of what the united states
always did and why i get so frustrated
when we sliding but i make no apologies
for it
we know these kinds of federal
investments work
it was the defense department and nasa
that got the modern semiconductor
industry
on its feet decades ago we
started your tax dollars
our own department of energy pioneered
and transformed the battery injury when
barack and i were in office
and through the recovery act grants and
loans
battery prices dropped 80 percent
80 because we were looking forward
we need that same mindset today
we have to look forward
and you know
we have to work to support consumers
and these fleets that means new
purchasing incentives for consumers to
buy clean vehicles like the electric
ford 150
a union made product right here in
america
but all the pieces must be made in
america
it means spurring demand by converting
the federal government's enormous fleet
of vehicles
into clean vehicles and supporting
electric transit systems
and school buses
folks when i got elected i signed an
executive order saying
we're going to buy america as president
i get to
award contracts in the area of 600 to
700 billion
a year from building aircraft carriers
to railings that go in
in buildings guess what
representative kelde knows i'm not
letting a single contract
to a single company that does not
hire americans have all-american parts
and has a
supply chain that is an american product
supply chain
wow by the way wow
that's not violating any trade agreement
it's been the law since the 30s but no
one's had the courage and the nerve
to insist on it being applied
it's no violation of the world trade
organization or anything else if we're
spending american tax dollars
we're able to say buy america but
there's a lot of exception in law if you
don't have the part immediately
available at flight 10 you can go abroad
and get it
and anyone in the agency can say i can't
find it here i'm going somewhere
not anymore they got to go through the
white house not a joke
nobody can give that exception
because there's thousands of companies
out there able to do
small companies 3 4 10 15 people
who can supply those pieces that they
know they can compete for them
my brother has an expression a guy named
pete mclaughlin was a great basketball
player played for providence was a good
close friend
he'd say joe you got to know how to know
you got to know how to know
we don't let the american companies know
what's available to them especially if
they're small
so we're going to have we have an office
in the facility in the white house
to let people know what's needed
and there's another thing we have in our
playbook that's going to out-compete
other nations
the biggest secret we have the american
worker whoa not a joke
the finest workforce in the world it's
our ace in that deck
now i know many of you watching at home
are like the folks i grew up with in
scranton and claim on delaware
they feel left out left behind
in an economy in an industry that's
rapidly changing
i understand it i really do
but we will leave no one behind
nearly 90 percent of the jobs created in
my american jobs plan
do not require a bachelor's degree
75 percent don't require a
associate's degree we're going to be
working with companies and community
colleges and technical schools and union
led apprentice and training programs
to make sure that american workers will
be prepared to compete with anyone in
the world
just like ford does with its workforce
training center here in dearborn
and when we invest in our infrastructure
we're going to buy american products
materials services for american
businesses
made in america and we'll do everything
in our power
to encourage and protect the right of
workers to unionize
and collectively bargain
strong statement
[Applause]
i met with i think it was more than a
dozen ceos of the major
fortune 500 companies we started off and
i said i want to be clear with you
i'm a union guy
and every one of them but one said i
understand
because now they're realizing what mr
ford realizes
that you are the best workers available
you're the best trained
you're the most capable and you save
overall
bottom line american jobs plan is a
blue-collar blueprint
to rebuild america a blue-collar
blueprint to build america
and we need automakers and other
companies to keep investing here in
america and not take the benefits of our
public investments and expand electric
vehicles and battery manufacturing
production abroad we need you to deepen
your partnership with the uaw pay good
wages support communities
like dearborn across the country we need
to come together as a nation
the vice president and i have had a
number of meetings in the oval office
with republican leaders in congress and
members of congress we believe we can
find a bipartisan deal on infrastructure
and we look forward to hearing more
details of their proposal which they're
going to submit
counter proposals either later today or
tomorrow to me
but we made one thing clear we'll
compromise
but doing nothing is not an option
doing nothing is not an option the world
is not waiting i say for a second time
i'll conclude with this last month
i kept my commitment to convene the
leaders of the major economies around
the world from russia
china india japan the european union
that's true
i convened them all i think there are 48
or 50
heads of state presidents and prime
ministers
a meeting i hosted by the white house
one of the most consequential issues
facing the world
the climate crisis and i made it clear
at the outset
as each of these folks came on what i've
long believed
when i think of the climate crisis
beyond its devastation the lives and
livelihoods and health of our very
planet
i think jobs i think
jobs when i think climate change good
paying
union jobs i think about the uaw workers
here today i wanted to make sure
that the world could see that there was
a consensus
that we are at an inflection point in
our history and almost
every major leader in the world spoke to
it
if we act to save the planet we can
create millions of
good paying jobs generates significant
economic growth and opportunity to raise
the standard
for people not only here but around the
world
but i also wanted to put the world on
notice
america is back america
is back in the comments
for the 21st century the future will be
built
right here in america look at this plan
we're moving we're working again we're
dreaming again we're discovering again
we're leading the world again we have
shown
each other in the world that there's no
quit in america there's simply no
quit in america and that's
never ever it's every time i have these
sometimes knocked down dragging outs
with heads of state in private
they'll say something i say look it's
never
been a good bet to bet against america
never
never never never this is the united
states of america there's not a single
thing
and i believe there's every fiber or
maybe not a single thing
nothing beyond our capacity when we act
together
and that's exactly what we're about to
do starting with all of you and thank
you for allowing me to be here
may god bless you and may god protect
our troops thank you
thank you thank you thank you
[Applause]
all right there is joe biden a very big
electric car charger announcement
which hopefully he will be able to get
funded right i mean that's really the
question there
uh but there goes joe biden putting his
mask on although he showed up with it
off and let's see if he'll jog out
uh no jogging right now all right let's
see if we can get this garden tour video
which we've been teasing i think people
are going to like this let's see if we
did it
okay hakfuey just grabbed a twitch sub
and his number 93. [ __ ] says
with a message central committee was
talking
smack about you he sounded jealous he
central committee sounds like an entity
like an organ is a committee is an
entity what does that mean he
it's a committee that identifies as male
i don't know what that is
but a lot of people talk smack about me
i don't know what to tell you hopefully
they made some money off of it you know
i hope
it trickles down i guess i would say but
no i don't know what that means
uh let's see fixie goob
has signed up in his number 94 via
twitch
shot thomas is number 95
and caspa is number 96.
next i think we're going to make it guys
roxanna onua just signed up at
joinpakman.com
andrew cravello just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
gabrielle hartman just signed up and
melissa
nori's just signed up that is
100 and then just to put us
over the top rue dobbs
i like that rue dobbs just made a
patreon pledge
patreon counts double today
double so we've done it we've done it
and i am now going to show you
this is the 2021 garden
heretofore unseen i will give you a full
tour of it
uh in all seriousness though if you're
an amazon prime
member make sure you're using your
twitch prime sub for someone it doesn't
have to be me i would love it if it were
that's five bucks that either it stays
with bezos or you give it to an
independent producer on twitch
so just make sure you're using it that's
my message okay
all right let's jump in here uh i will
pause and explain what's going on
this is swiss chard right here two swiss
chard plants and this is a jalapeno
pepper
all right so the chard is mostly looking
good that one leaf
there not great here's a pepper plant
no no peppers yet but that is a um
that's a jalapeno
uh plant all right so swiss chard and
jalapeno
this is a purple lettuce it's doing
really well i had some of it last night
in a salad for dinner
um i don't even know what it it it was
called gourmet lettuce mix
when i planted it but um
i just call it purple lettuce look at
that growth though
really strong growth coming in from the
middle this is my perennial mint now
the the soil looks like crap because
since it's a perennial i didn't want to
kind of like re-till it this season
um so i haven't touched it and it's like
there's little stones and stuff in it
but mint is so
robust that it's coming back on its own
really really strongly now one thing
that is
concerning me is last year i had two
types of mint i had like a spearmint and
some other mint
was one was fuzzy one was not only one
of the types of mint has come back so
that's cool
this is a tomato these are i believe
these are called
chocolate minis it's like a brownish red
almost um i think it's i don't think it
tastes like chocolate i think it's just
the color
so that's pretty nice uh that's geneva
genovese basil this is a
parsley here's a another what is that
sun
sugar yellow tomatoes these are still
pretty early on right now
all right and then a little more of my
genovese basil
a lot of basil happening i actually
planted purple basil and thai basil and
then i was away for a week
and they really need water at the
beginning so i already lost my purple
basil and my thai basil
i'm hoping now to keep keep the basil
alive
all right sun sugar yellow cherry hybrid
tomato yeah so that's that so
a bunch of different stuff all right
here's my biggest tomato plant
and as you can see i've sort of kept it
i've gotten rid of the suckers and i've
gotten rid of
um a lot of those low branches
last year that worked and i got i got
hundreds of tomatoes now is that that
looks like a weed there
oh i pull it look at that done
these are my cukes my cukes are really
sad and tiny
um i planted this a little too late
but as you can see the trellis there so
hopefully these will soon
start to grow and and go up the trellis
this is what's called
a lemon cuke i'd never seen this before
they're yellow i don't know that they
taste like lemon but they are yellow
cucumbers
uh yeah all right then look at this
these are my green peas look at these
robust tendrils have you seen
tendrils like this before um
these are going wild i think i have four
plants
they're going everywhere so i i really
am hoping
to get some really strong uh i believe
these are sugar snap peas
sugar snap peas um
and they are just shooting tendrils
everywhere some of the tendrils are
wrapping around each other
uh yeah okay so that's that those are
going
this is my um so i have two types of
oregano
i have i guess it's like italian oregano
and greek oregano i think this might be
the greek
i didn't even uh plant this uh i didn't
think oregano was a perennial
it came back on its own i just gave it a
haircut and made a huge pesto out of it
um incredible growth
robust strong growth for the greek
oregano
this is another type of pepper i believe
that this is a um
this is a banana pepper plant my pepper
plants always grow really slowly
and then all of a sudden i get a bunch
of peppers here's another tomato
very early on and then here's another
pepper i know that the pepper's too
close to the tomato i understand that
you don't need to tell me i know it's
supposed to have like three feet or
something crazy
it did okay last year it just ended up
being close together what can i do okay
please don't shame me here is the
italian oregano and again
look at this growth i have done nothing
with it
last year it was good i just
trimmed this and it's already just
exploding
here's my time also doing really well
cilantro i've never had cilantro do this
well i think the difference is this year
i
um separated out the cilantro a little
bit
at the base instead of planting it all
in a really small space
just spread it out these are japanese
eggplants now what i did
i planted the one on the right first
which as you can see is bigger
and it did well enough that i said i'm
gonna get a second plant if you put all
your eggs in one basket with eggplant
you might get nothing so i got a second
japanese eggplant that's on the left
uh i'm hoping i get one eggplant out of
it i don't know what i'm doing with
eggplant i've never planted it before
so i think that that hopefully will be
nice and then this is the big boy
this is my strawberry plant now
strawberries are perennial
last year many of you remember the
infamous strawberry eating video
i got six red strawberries last year
and i knew that it was really a
three-year project
look at this this is all i mean it's
early in the season i think there's 20
or 30
strawberry buds here
look at some of these look at that huh
now i know that this early in the season
some people say to pull the flowers
and let the plant grow and then later
let the um uh strawberries do i'm just
leaving it
i'm just leaving it and it's even shot
out um
a uh sorry what's called when it shoots
out a new thing
a uh runner and it's almost like an
entire second strawberry plant and as
you can see right here we've already got
a bunch of strawberries going
so that's the strawberry plant really
doing well
i have high hopes and then my chard is
still there didn't go anywhere so that's
exciting stuff
okay and then lastly here's a bonus
i do have um
romaine growing as well okay
so this is just a little bit of a bonus
it's because people were so polite today
i'm going to show you guys my romaine
hold on where is this here we go so look
at this this is four romaine plants i
harvested
the the harvested the large leaves
yesterday and made a salad with that
purple lettuce
really nicely growing really really
nicely growing that's some nice romaine
and uh just great just great a lot of
thickness on the leaf
yep very very much so i didn't really
know how to harvest this so i just went
in and took the biggest leaves and just
cut them carefully down at the
down at the base all right guys so
that's the uh that's the garden that's
what i've got going as things like i
think the lettuce doesn't last long into
the season
so once it's done i think the lettuce
will only go through
through june i'll plant something else
in that's my idea
okay uh jeremy says where's the tomatoes
i showed you my three tomato plants
yeah i don't know what you guys are
talking about okay all right everybody
appreciate it thanks to everybody who
subbed via twitch remember to use those
twitch subs use them for someone okay
um go ahead and grab those website
memberships
we love the super chats we have many
many more streams coming this week
and i will keep you posted from the
standpoint of fruits and vegetables all
right everybody see you very soon